the characters in one division went
through more than a few transformations
over the course of the nine episode show
now it's time to unravel the mysteries
of one division to determine which
characters are more than meet ci
one division second episode ushers in a
character who after a moment's
hesitation
introduces herself as geraldine her
hesitation is warranted
as we find out a couple episodes later
geraldine is actually none other than
monica rambo
while mcu fans might not recognize the
debuting taeyana paris
monica is a character we've met before
it's just that she was a little bit
younger in captain marvel
the daughter of maria rambo monica plays
a direct role in the events of captain
marvel
even facilitating some important color
changes in danvers
iconic costume it's no surprise that a
grown-up version of monaco has been
introduced in the mcu
marvel comics readers know her as a
superhero in her own right
under a few different code names
including captain marvel
in fact paris is scheduled to reprise
the role of monika in captain marvel 2.
time moves strangely in the world of one
division particularly when you're trying
to track trimesters
episode 2 begins with wonder and vision
suggestively turning off the light in
their bedroom
and ends with wonder pregnant and
already showing after a single day
by the end of episode 3 she's given
birth to two boys
tommy and billy as of the end of one
division tommy and billy are a little
too young to be donning spandex
and may or may not exist in a corporal
form anymore but it's impossible to
ignore the connotations of those names
in marvel comics tommy shepard and billy
kaplan are in fact
the superheroic children of vision and
scarlet witch
brought into being via an extremely
complicated series of events
involving witches reincarnation and a
demon
tommy aka speed has powers inherited
from his uncle pietro
like pietro tommy can move at incredible
speed something his father
vision is also seen doing in episode 3.
billy meanwhile has reality warping
powers akin to his mothers
and goes by the name of wiccan wicken
and speed are both members of the
adolescent superhero team the young
avengers and considering that the mcu is
getting ready to introduce other young
heroes from the comics
an mcu version of the young avengers
complete with tommy and billy
appears to be in the making the fourth
episode of one division is the first to
break from the show's early format
stepping outside the in-universe sitcom
to show viewers what's been happening in
the world beyond westview
in addition to providing more to the
story of monica rambo
this also allows one division to
reintroduce us to fbi agent jimmy wu
played by randall park the mcu version
of wu
first appeared in 2018's ant-man and the
wasp where he's been charged with making
sure scott lang remains securely under
house arrest
in one division he at least appears
reasonably competent
though he hasn't strayed too far from
his roots as a comedy character
of course the jimmy wu of marvel comics
law is hardly a punchline he appeared in
1956
as part of the short-lived yellow claw
series published by atlas comics
which would later evolve into marvel one
of comic's first asian american heroes
he's been bouncing around the marvel
universe ever since
becoming part of shield and leading
multiple superhero teams
it's unclear if the mcu's jimmy wu will
ever take on the significance of his
comics counterpart
but his inclusion in one division could
suggest a larger role to come
authority looks good on you jimmy
jimmy wu isn't the only familiar face
who shows up in episode 4 of one
division
the show has officially brought back one
of the oldest characters in the mcu
darcy lewis you death threatened me
thor was so punier
[Music]
what he was freaking me out who first
appeared in the franchise's fourth film
thor in 2011. played by kat dennings the
snarky intern was one of the best parts
of the movie
and dennings reprised her role in 2013's
thor the dark world
but she hadn't been seen since until one
division brought her back
giving us a look at what darcy has been
up to in the last decade of mcu
continuity
she's come a long way i thought you were
a science major political science
the most notable thing we learn is that
darcy is now a doctor of astrophysics
like her former mentor jane foster her
personality hasn't changed much
but she's a driving force in helping
sword learn about what's happening in
westview
while the third film in the thor
franchise thor ragnarok
seemed to be something of a disavowal of
the first two the franchise has done an
about phase by bringing back
natalie portman for the fourth chapter
thor love and thunder
could darcy be returning to the
mainstream mcu as well
prior to one division mcu fans could be
forgiven for forgetting that wonder
maximoff had a brother
pietro maximoff only appeared in one
film avengers age of ultron
and by the end of it he was dead he has
gone unmentioned in the movies ever
since
wonders limited screen time in ensemble
films like captain america
civil war and avengers infinity war has
been largely devoted to her relationship
with vision
one division brings back the speedster
in episode 5 but with a twist
one division's pietro isn't played by
aaron taylor johnson
as he was in age of ultron but evan
peters who portrayed a different version
of quicksilver
peter maximoff in the last three
installments of fox's x-men franchise
in 2015 the existence of the two
characters was something of an inside
joke
quicksilver has been both an x-men and
an avenger giving both [ __ ] and disney
a case for including him
unfortunately for anyone hoping for an
official x-men crossover into one
division
monika discovers that the fake piedro is
actually just a brainwashed westview
resident
with a truly unfortunate name you're
ralph boner
boner there had been plenty of clues
over the first six episodes of one
division
that wonders neighbor agnes wasn't
exactly what she seemed
and in episode 7 we finally got
confirmation
agnes is in fact agatha harkness a
character from marvel comics with
long-standing ties to the scarlet witch
as the end of the episode drives home
park nurses a witch herself
and has been magically manipulating the
events of one division
since the very beginning the comics
version of agatha harkness dates back to
1970
when she first appeared in the pages of
the fantastic four in contrast to one
division's delightfully sinister montage
she has primarily been a heroic figure
in the comics
fighting alongside the fantastic four
and the avengers on several occasions
when they've dealt with magical threats
most directly relevant however is her
association with wonder
harkness was wanda's mentor and trainer
in the use of magic and she's been a
recurring scarlet witch side character
ever since
as one division viewers discover over
the course of the show
director heywood has a hidden agenda
specifically reassembling vision's
lifeless corpse so he can be wiped clean
of his humanity
and used as a sentient weapon he gets
his wish toward the end of the season
using wonders chaos magic to power up an
emotionless vision more importantly for
long time marvel readers
it also calls back to an arc from the
comics in which vision
died and was later brought back albeit
without the brain waves that gave his
earlier incarnation its humanity
cold emotionless and just as pale as the
synthezoids seen in one division
this version of the vision no longer
loves a scarlet witch which splits up
one of marvel's most popular comics
couples
one division viewers familiar with this
storyline will know that vision
eventually gets back to his old self
and the show seems to take care of that
plot development when the two visions
square off in the westview town library
after receiving a memory transfer from
his magical doppelganger
vision 2.0 flies off for parts unknown
at this point there's no telling where
or when he'll turn up next
but it seems pretty clear that we
haven't seen the last of vision
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book heroes and
villains are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one